j'accueille bruno gaccio
j incorrigible baffie il fait c'est à
tout le monde la vie comme ça les gens
une demi heure il cherche lui vont
s'asseoir et et parce que rappelons que
les gens sont cons alors bruno les
guignols sont très en forme en ce moment
merci à dire que l'actualité est créé un
bon scénario quand même pour les lignes
avant de rire d'une info on la subit
quand même vrai hélas quand et tous les
jours dans un bureau on est quatre et on
parle de l'actualité et tous les jours
on parle de racisme on parle on cite
sarkozy tous les jours au bout d'un
moment dans la humain et on s'est dit ah
trop de mou donc faut arrêter on fait
trois minutes de silence et on essaie
mercredi c'est encore ça c'est pas le
meilleur mais c'est vrai que je dis pas
ça pour être désagréable à un mail y
avait longtemps que les guignols n'avait
pas été dans le ton monte heure de jeu
mais les guignols non c'est pas vrai du
tout alors c'est pas que jamais les
grilles alger est mêlée gagnée quand il
était drôle et je suis client je suis
demandeur pour que les guignols me fasse
rire et là tu fonces que nouveaux rôles
en tout cas juste en tout cas ya
longtemps que prévu d'escale
je me dis [ __ ] là c'est bien la toile
merci laurent mais si la qualité peut
agir
c'est vrai que ça va pas pleurer pendant
8 10 sport com est un gros passage à
vide
je viens de revenir c'est pour faire
alors bruno les hasards du calendrier
font que vous participez à un livre
collectif édité par unicef qui s'appelle
fais moi ta déclaration
lesdits droits de l'enfant dans lequel
sous la houlette de tristane banon dix
auteurs ont écrit une nouvelle sur les
droits de l'enfant
riad d'anne frank est allé cassis que
nous recevons tout à l'heure il ya
vincent ravalec à bernard werber et vous
voilà alors vous votre nouvelle c'est le
droit d'être protégé contre
l'exploitation
ouais alors je fais le pitch de la
nouvelle de bruno c'est six enfants
obèses qui décide de se révolter contre
l'industrie agroalimentaire et quitte
nappe le pdg d'une boîte qui fait des
crêpes surgelés à la confiture de fraise
et il lui met une fessée cul nu devant
les télés du monde entier
ouais télé mondiale un fait c'est
mondiale [ __ ] de grosse fessée
mondiale parce que c'est tout ce qu'ils
méritent ces mecs là c'est la première
fois que j'ai eu envie de mettre une
fessée à un type et je sais plus si
c'est pinault arnault ils sont toujours
les deux je les confonds tout le temps
il y en a un qui avait eu il y avait 40
2 millions de francs à l'époque de sur
son compte en banque il avait demandé un
crédit à sa banque pour de 42 millions
pour éviter de payer l'impôt sur la
fortune
ouais et je vais te dis c'est vraiment
cci que roncquois et qu'est-ce qu'on
peut faire lui mettre une fessée il ya
que satan vie lui met une fessée salles
prévue plaît le banquier stern savez
plaisait les faits c'est même toit avec
des raquettes de ping pong il aime bien
falloir tarifs qui avaient été publiées
pour l'anniversaire de la déclaration
des droits de l'enfant le 20 novembre
c'est la journée mondiale de l'enfance
et c'est l'occasion pour l'unicef de
mobiliser pour les enfants contre le
sida
il ya un enfant qui meurt du sida dans
le monde toutes les minutes
ouais mais surtout ce qui est ce qui a
fait atroce et qui montre encore une
fois
en l'espèce de d'égoïsme de l'occident
on va dire bêtement c'est que chez nous
par exemple les transmission mère-enfant
du sida des femmes enceintes n'y en a
plus voilà on a réussi à régler ce
problème là et en afrique il y en a une
toutes les 15 secondes
mais comme nous le problème est réglé on
s'occupe plus de rien il ya plus de
crédit à plus de recherche est plus que
dalle et il faudrait juste rappeler aux
gens quand même que les petits enfants
même s'ils sont un peu noir c'est des
êtres humains sont en train de mourir
moi j'ai jamais rien fait dans
l'humanitaire pas ce qu'on me demandait
rien alors quand on demandait rien
savate et planque était tranquille le
jour où on me demande si tôt qu'ils
n'ont pas vraiment pour un [ __ ] quand
même alors ce qu'il faut dire nos amis
téléspectateurs tu as des clients que je
vis ici donc l'unicef c'est la première
organisation du monde consacré aux
enfants
elle est présente dans 157 pays et elle
est uniquement financée par les dons
volontaires voilà